ALL RIGHT WELL WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. FOR THE IS
APRIL TENTH AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE.
MR JOHNSON WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT IN PLACE OF MR LEVINE.
BUT IS NOT [inaudible]
SEVEN YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE THERE ARE OTHER WITH
THE FIVE EIGHT ALREADY RECORDED
THAT'S A GOOD DAY -- FOR YOUR
OWN PROTECTION.
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT MAKES TO
SMALL TECHNICAL FIXES AND THE
BUSINESS OF PROFESSIONALS.
PROFESSIONS CODE FOR CANNABIS
CULTIVATION AND LABELING THE
FIRST PICS STANDARDIZES CANNABIS
CULTIVATION LICENCES BY
ADDRESSING THE DISCREPANCY AND
TYPE ONE C. LICENSES.
THE SECOND FIX CLARIFIES
LANGUAGE RELATED TO CANNABIS
APPELLATIONS AND INCLUDES OF
ORIGIN INTO THAT DEFINITION
OVERALL AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT IT'S
A SIMPLE CLEAN A BILL THAT MAKES
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING CHANGES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT TO PROVIDE FURTHER
TESTIMONY ON HIS BILL IS LOUIS
BROWN OF THE INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
MISTER BROWN.
IT WAS FANTASTIC.
THAT WAS A BASIC INTRODUCTION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE INTO INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION.
JUST AS OUR AUTHOR STATED THIS
IS REALLY A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
BILL -- BUT ONE THAT MAKES A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE -- FOR
THOSE IN THE INDUSTRY A
PARTICULARLY WITH THE
CLARIFICATION FOR THE SPECIALTY
COTTAGE LICENSE WHICH YOU'RE
TRADITIONALLY SMALL FARMERS --
AND ADDING A SQUARE FOOTAGE
ALLOWANCE TO THAT WOULD THEN
BRING IT INTO LINE WITH ALL THE
OTHER LICENSES.
AND THEN MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THOSE SMALL FARMERS CAN QUALIFY
FOR THAT KADDISH LICENSE A JUST
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE LICENSE
PRICE.
MAKES A SIGNIFICANT --
SUBSTANTIAL -- ISSUE FOR THOSE
SMALL FARMERS AND SO -- IT IS A
MINOR CHANGE IN STATUTE BUT A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FOR THE
INDUSTRY WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY.
COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS KAREN
WAGNER AND I AM FROM HUMBLE
COUNTY I AM A HAVE MY
MANUFACTURING LICENSE JUST GOT
MY FULL ANNUAL LICENSE WILL WHO.
HI I'M A DISTRIBUTOR AND A SMALL
CULTIVATOR I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH AND MIL ROUTE -- I'M A
TRIANGLE CULT OF POLITICS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME FROM THE VERY
FIRST TIME WHEN WE HAD.
AMIL GROWERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND NOW HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS
ASSOCIATION I AM HERE.
TO PLEAD WITH YOU TO PUT THE
ORIGINAL LANGUAGE BACK IN THE
BILL.
THAT ALLOWED FOR A SON GROWN AG
COMMISSION.
I AM TERRIBLY DISMAYED THAT THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THEMSELVES TO REPRESENT.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF SMALL
FARMERS IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND
HAVE THAT LANGUAGE STRUCK.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE SMALL
GROWERS OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY HAVE
A SON GROWN ADD COMMISSION IN
ORDER TO BETTER COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
I AM ON THE FRONT LINES I THINK
HE'S TELLING THESE ARE YOU SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OR
MUSICIAN I'M SPEAK.
WELL I GUESS I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF REINSTATING THE
ORIGINAL LANGUAGE IN THE BILL I
DO SUPPORT ALL OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE BILL BUT THE ORIGINAL BILL
HAVE THE SUN GROWN ACTIVE THE
THE ABILITY TO FORM A SONG GROWN
AG COMMISSION.
AND THROUGH THE LOBBYING EFFORTS
OF ONE OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTY THAT LANGUAGE
WAS STRUCK AND SO I'M VERY
DISMAYED ABOUT THAT AND I PLEAD.
FOR ADDITIONAL TIME IN ORDER TO
GATHER MORE SUPPORT FROM OUR
FARMERS THAT DESPERATELY NEED
THIS SON GROWN ACT COMMISSION IN
ORDER TO BETTER COMPETE IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
OKAY WELL THIS IS THIS BILL IF
IT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A ALL A LOT
MORE TIME FOR MORE CONVERSATIONS
TO OCCUR.
AS THE PROCESS GOES FORWARD BUT
I THINK YOU FOR COMING DOWN FROM
HUMBLE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING I
APPRECIATE IT.
ANYBODY ELSE SPEAKING CAN
POTENTIAL SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NONE OF BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE ARE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YET -- NO WE NEED.
SIX AND WE'RE GONNA BUT SO BUT I
THINK I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING THIS FOR TODAY AND FOR THE
SMALL FIX I KNOW YOU WERE ONE OF
THE FOUNDING FATHERS -- AND SO
WE ALWAYS -- ENJOY YOUR
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RIGHT NOW WILL BE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS.
IN ADDITION TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE BUT WHAT THAT
FOR HOW ABOUT I'M I'M AN AUTHOR
SO I WILL TURN THIS OVER RIGHT
NOW TO MR MATHIS.
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD PRESENT
AB
.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY LOOKS LIKE WE OF CORN
COULD [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
HERE EGGMAN HERE MATHIS HERE
MATHIS HERE AGGIE A CURRY.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HERE FLORA.
GRAY -- WHEN?
I WHEN HERE JONES SAWYER -- SO
YOU'RE HERE QUIRK ROBERT RIVAS
SALAS [inaudible]
CELLS PRESENT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE
CAN OFFICIALLY START.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS --
THE DATA SHOWS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE
GROUP OF PEOPLE FORMING IN THE
UNITED STATES WE ARE VERY PROUD
OF THAT -- BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ARE ESTABLISH FARMERS ARE ALSO
GROWING OLDER THE OLDER
GENERATION OF PRODUCERS IS
RAPIDLY AGING OUT WELL YOUNGER
GENERATIONS OF EXISTING FARMING
FAMILIES ARE INCREASINGLY
CHOOSING TO LEAVE THE SECTOR.
SO WE NEED TO FIND ALWAYS WE CAN
TO ENCOURAGE MORE PEOPLE TO COME
INTO THE TO THE BUSINESS -- IN
ORDER TO TRULY BE SUSTAINABLE.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
THESE DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS BY
LOOKING AT WAYS.
TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY WE KNOW
THERE'S A DIVERSE GROUP OF
PEOPLE LIVING IN CALIFORNIA --
AND FARMING IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW DO WE PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
THAT.
SO AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT SIX TO
DO THIS BY ESTABLISHING THE
FORMER EQUITY AND INNOVATION
CENTER A COORDINATED STATEWIDE
PROGRAM FOCUSING ON HELPING
SMALL FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
PARTICULAR FARMERS AND RANCHERS
OF COLOR.
THE SENATOR THE CENTER IS
MODELED AFTER THE SMALL FORM
PROGRAM THAT EXISTED FOR DECADES --
UNDER THE UC.
I'M CULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT WAS ENDED DUE TO
BUDGET CUTS FOLLOWING THE GREAT
RECESSION.
WELL THERE ARE STILL FOR SMALL
FORWARD BIJAN THE STATE AND
NUMEROUS UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION STAFF WHO WORK ON
SMALL FARM ISSUES.
THESE EFFORTS ARE DESPERATE IN
CAN VERY AND FOCUS ACROSS THE
MANY PROGRAMS OF THE UC OPERATES.
THE FORM EQUITY AND INNOVATION
CENTER WILL ACT AS A CENTRAL HUB
TO COORDINATE BETWEEN THE SMALL
FARM ADVISORS AN EXISTING YOU
SEE A AND R..
PROGRAMS WITH THE SMALL FORM
NEXUS WHILE PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES TO SMALL FARMERS AND
RANCHERS.
WE FORESEE THE CENTER OFFERING
ASSISTANCE WITH FARM RANCH
MANAGEMENT MARKETING RESEARCH
RELATED TO WATER MANAGEMENT AIR
QUALITY AS WELL AS GENERAL
FARMING TECHNIQUES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH GRANT LOAN
APPLICATIONS AND FORMER.
TO FARM WORKER TO FORMER
TRAINING AS WE KNOW OUR STATE
PASSES A LOT OF LAWS AND
REGULATIONS -- THAT HAS
SOMETIMES PUSH THINGS TO A
LARGER MORE CORPORATE WAY OF
FARMING WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE SMALL FARMERS
SMALL FARMING FAMILIES.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THEY NEED
SOME SOMETIMES THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THE BIG LIKE A TO HIRE THEIR OWN
COMPLIANCE OFFICER SO THESE
PROGRAMS WILL BE SET UP TO BE
ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
NEED AND I HAVE THREE FIND
WITNESSES HERE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT.
WE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND
MASS OF POOR SUPPORT SUPPORT
SUPPORT SO WHO BE AS BRIEF AND
GET TO THE POINT THANK YOU RIGHT.
WELL I THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY --
MY NAME IS MARK RUTH DAHLQUIST
WILLARD AND I'M A SMALL FARMS
ADVISER IN FRESNO AND TULARE
COUNTIES SO ONE OF THE FOUR THAT
WAS MENTIONED THAT STILL REMAIN.
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL THE OTHER
SMALL FARMS ADVISORS AS WELL I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS BILL AND I
THINK IT REALLY COULD GREATLY
EXPAND THE WORK THAT WE DO -- SO --
AS WITH DESCRIBES WE CURRENTLY
PROVIDE EXTENSION SUPPORT TO
FARMERS WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY.
NOT BEEN REACHED OUT WELL BY
EXTENSIONAL A TRADITIONAL
EXTENSION PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY
THE SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS -- FOR EXAMPLE IN FRESNO
WHERE I MUSCLE FARMS ADVISER
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE MOM
FARMING COMMUNITY GOING BACK
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE THOSE LONG
TERM TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS
OFFERING PRACTICAL SUPPORT --
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THINGS
LIKE HELP SOME OF THESE FARMERS
APPLY FOR SWEET FUNDING.
SO FAR WE'VE HAD OVER ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SWEET GRANTS
THAT WERE AWARDED TO THESE
FARMERS THROUGH OUR ASSISTANCE
WHO WOULDN'T OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT PROGRAM -- I
ALSO LEVERAGE OTHER RESOURCES
WITHIN A IN OUR TO HELP THESE
FARMERS FROM PROGRAMS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON
SMALL SCALE FARMS BUT THAT.
I'M ABLE TO BRING THOSE
RESOURCES AND FOR EXAMPLE IN
FRESNO WE HAVE A VEGETABLE CROPS
ADVISER.
WHO MAINLY SERVES A LARGE SCALE
COMMODITIES LIKE PROCESSING
TOMATOES ON THE WEST SIDE OF
FRESNO -- BUT BECAUSE I'M
THERE'S A SMALL FARMS ADVISER I
CAN BRING THE GROWERS TO HIM WHO
NEED EXTRA SUPPORT WITH FOR
EXAMPLE DIAGNOSING DISEASES ON
THEIR SPECIALTIES AND VEGETABLE
CROPS AND BECAUSE WE CAN MAKE
THAT CONNECTION.
THEY'RE ABLE TO RECEIVE THAT
SUPPORT AS WELL -- SO WE'RE
DOING THE BEST WE CAN WITH THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE --
IN IN OUR TO PROVIDE EXTENSION
SUPPORT. TO THESE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS -- AND SO WHILE WE
DO STILL HAVE SOME SMALL FIRMS
WERE GOING ON THERE'S MANY
FARMERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT WE CAN'T ADEQUATELY SUPPORT.
OF FOR EXAMPLE IN FRESNO AND
TULARE COUNTIES COMBINED WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL FARMS --
AND THERE ARE MANY SIMILAR FARMS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ESPECIALLY MERRY BETWEEN FRESNO
SACRAMENTO WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
SMALL FARMS ADVISERS IN THOSE
COUNTIES -- AND THEY WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM EXTENSION
SUPPORT -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT IN OUR IS DEALING
WITH THE PROBLEM OF PROBABLE
SHORTAGE OF FUNDS RIGHT NOW.
DUE TO OUR FLAT BUDGETS -- IN IF
IT DOES REMAIN FLAT WE MAY BE
LOOKING AT CUTS TO ALL OF OUR
STATEWIDE PROGRAM SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE FLAT BUDGET WITH
A NEW STATEWIDE PROGRAM BEING
PROPOSED.
WE JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT ANY
STATEWIDE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
MANDATED BY THE BILL ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AND I KNOW
THAT'S A SEPARATE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE BUDGET.
SO.
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING THIS LEGISLATION AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP IF
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT FURTHER.
THANK YOU.
PLUS I WANNA ECHO -- RUTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY BEARD ALSO SUPPORT
MY NAME IS BORN STRONG AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ASIAN
BUSINESSES WHO RESOURCE AND
CENTER.
AND WOMEN FORTUNE OF TO PARTNER
WITH THEM -- FOR THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS BUT REALLY WORKED HARD
WITH OUR SMALL FARMERS -- WITHIN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OF HOLES OF
ISSUES AND SOME THE BIGGEST
THING IS CULTURAL COMPETENCY AN
APPROPRIATE -- NISSEN TERMS
WORKING WITH THESE FARMERS IT IS
SO CRITICAL TO HAVE.
AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO REACH TO THIS ISSUE NO
FARMING IS A LIVELIHOOD FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
AS A MEANS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SUSTAINABLE FAMILY UNIT
TO GOING BACK ON ON ON SUPPORT.
AND SO THE SMALL FARMING --
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY WITH
NEEDED RESOURCE WE HAVE.
IT IS IS NEEDED BECAUSE OF
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGE IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF POLICIES ISSUES
THAT ARE COMING THROUGH.
AND TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
AGENCY THAT CAN HELP US TO
PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL SAYS AND
WHAT WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY ON
THE CULTURAL SIDE.
IS IS IS AN INCREDIBLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITY IS ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO FORM BUT ALSO TO
SUPPORT AND AND THAT IS WHY
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT AND AND I
HOPE THAT -- YOU GUYS CONSIDER
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT WHAT'S
NEEDED BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE JUST
ONE PIECE IN CENTRAL VALLEY BUT
THERE'S A HUGE COMMUNITY THAT'S
UP IN MERCED STOCKTON SACRAMENTO
YOU BEAR.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN TOUCH AND WE
WERE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SIMILAR SERVICES AT AND
SUSTAINABILITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AGAIN THIS BILL HAS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
I WOULD ADD ANYTHING OTHER THAN
PAUL TOWERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE COMMUNITY LIGHTS WITH
FAMILY FARMERS BASED IN DAVIS
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND A
SPOT COSPONSORED THIS BILL.
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
AGRICULTURAL LAND BASED TRAINING
ASSOCIATION IN THE SALINAS
VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
ERNESTO BAEZA HERE WITH THE
NATIONAL FARMERS COALITION THE
CALIFORNIA FROM JUST CLEVER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL DIMMICK FROM RICHARD
CHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BEST SELLER WITH A CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARMING NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A SMOKER WITH PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PLAN A BREAK WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ON
WEREN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL GREEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY --
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
SCENE NINE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ARE THERE THERE'S ALREADY --
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
EGGMAN.
HI EGGMAN AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
A GEAR PERIOD I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM ON A FLORA
[inaudible]
GRAY -- WHEN -- WHEN I'D JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
QUIRK?
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN BILLS OUT YOUR BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ENGAGED WITH MISTER COMING.
MR KERRY PREPARED I'M IN WHY SHE
SETS -- SECRETARY -- CREATE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS.
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MR SAUCES ARE CUNNINGHAM SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AB EIGHTEEN NO
ONE EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE MATHIS
AYE MATHIS AYE A GEAR CURRY.
A YEAR CARRY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA.
HEY -- WHEN -- WHEN NIGHT JONES
SAWYER?
JONES SAWYER AYE.
QUIRK [inaudible]
THIS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIGN SALAS.
SOUTHSIDE.
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN ADOPTED I SEE NEXT UP WE
HAVE MISSED AND YOUR CURRY --
YEAH BEFORE WE BEFORE WE DO THAT
IF WE CAN.
GET A MOTION ON THE BILL THAT
WAS MOTION TO MOVE ON AV. EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT SECOND.
SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS ADMIN HI EGGMAN AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AG YEAR CURRY HI AGAIN
CURRY I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
GREAT -- WHEN?
HI IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE QUIRK.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT NOW.
WE HAVE A YOU ARE CURRY ON DOING
A BEEF NINE FIFTY EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA ORGANIC TO SCHOOL
PILOT PROGRAM MOTION WITH THE
BILL SECOND.
THANKS FOR OUR MEMBERS ON MAKE
THIS QUICK AB NINE FIFTY IT
CREATES CALIFORNIA ORGANIC TO
SCHOOL PART OF PROGRAM WHICH
WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS TO APPLY FOR
UP TO FIFTEEN CENTS.
OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING PER MEAL
TO PURCHASE ORGANIC.
CALIFORNIA GROWN LOCALLY
PRODUCED FOODS WELL COSTS IN
AVAILABILITY ISSUES PREVENT MANY
COMMUNITIES FROM ACCESSING.
LOCAL AND IN SEASON FOODS MEALS
PROVIDE THE SCHOOL SETTING A
PRACTICAL WAY TO INCREASE
CHILDREN'S NUTRITION.
OF THIS -- TO DETERMINE ACCESS
SUCCESS OF THE PILOT BOTH THE
PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG WILL
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATOR ON
THE OUTCOMES THIS REPORTING IS
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE WHETHER INVESTING IN
PROVIDING KIDS WITH HEALTHY
LOCAL FOODS.
IS MONEY WELL SPENT I'M WORKING
WITH MANY THE STAKEHOLDERS HERE
AND I HAVE WITNESSES HERE WITH
ME TODAY AND THEY CAN AND DO
SOME CELLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST WITNESSED AND SUPPORT
PLEASE MADAM TURN COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT ON A. B.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT MY NAME IS
JENNA MULLER -- I'M AN OWNER OF
FULL BELLY FARM WE ARE A FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY ACRE AGAIN A FARM
IN WESTERN YOLO COUNTY WE GROW
ABOUT EIGHTY DIFFERENT THINGS ON
OUR FARM.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR -- AND WE
SELL OUR PRODUCE IN THE
WHOLESALE MARKETS THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY SUPPORTED AGRICULTURE
PROGRAM -- AND ALSO AT FARMERS
MARKETS -- WE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY
FULL TIME YEAR ROUND EMPLOYEES.
ORGANIC FARMS ARE INEVITABLY
GOING TO EXPERIENCE SOME GROWING
PAINS IN THE COMING YEARS WE
HAVE A LOT OF OUR COSTS RISING
INCLUDING THE COST OF LABOR THE
COST OF FUEL ACOSTA COMPOST THE
COST OF HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND THE PRICE OF FOOD IS LARGELY
STAYING THE SAME.
SO FORGET IT FARMS TO SURVIVE
AND THRIVE IN THE COMING YEARS
WE NEED TO GET MORE CREATIVE IN
OUR SALES OUTLETS AND FIND NEW
MARKETS FOR AGAIN ECKLEY GROWN
FOOD.
AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT AS A WAY TO
HELP SUPPORT ORGANIC FARMS IN A
CHANGING AND CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT.
AWFUL BELLY FARM MY FARM HAS
BEEN PARTNERING WITH THE WINTERS
JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR THE PAST FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS -- EVERY WEEK WE DELIVER
ORGANIC FOOD DIRECTLY TO THE
SCHOOL WHICH THEY THEN USE IN
THEIR SCHOOL LUNCHES.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
RELATIONSHIP THE WINTER SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS PURCHASED OVER
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
WORTH OF FOOD FROM OUR FARM --
THIS IS BEEN AN EXTREMELY
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE FOR US NOT
JUST ON A FINANCIAL LEVEL ONE
CRITICISM OF THE ORGANIC MODEL
IS THAT IT IS INACCESSIBLE TO
THOSE WITHOUT A SUFFICIENTLY
HIGH INCOME.
AS THE COST OF PRODUCTION IS
HIGHER THAN CONVENTIONALLY GROWN
FOOD WE AS FARMERS MUCH CHARGE A
HIGH ENOUGH PRICE TO KEEP OUR
FARMS FINANCIALLY VIABLE.
BUYING DIRECTLY FROM OUR FIRM IS
MEANT TO THE SCHOOL CHILDREN IN
WINTERS HOW THEY ARE ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EAT
SEASONALLY AND EXPERIENCE TRULY
FRESH AND HEALTHY FOOD.
AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT IS ONE MUCH
NEEDED STEP IN THE DIRECTION OF
GETTING CALIFORNIA GROWN ORGANIC
FOOD INTO THE DAILY LIVES OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
OF CREATING A PATHWAY BETWEEN
ORGANIC FARMS AND THOSE WHO NEED
BETTER ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT MY NAME IS
BRANDY TRAVEL BEST AND I AM THE
FOOD SERVICES DIRECTOR AT NAPA
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I AM THE FIRST FOOD SERVICES
DIRECTOR THAT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAD I TOOK OVER FROM A
FOOD SERVICE MANAGEMENT COMPANY
THAT OPERATED OUR PROGRAM FOR
OVER THREE DECADES -- IN NAPA
COUNTY BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST OBESITY AND
CHILDHOOD CANCER RATE IN THE BAY
AREA.
ARE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE 55%
HISPANIC IN OVER 50% OF THE
CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
QUALIFY FOR THE SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM.
SO IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAT
WERE TAKING CARE OF OUR KIDS IN
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE AND
SERVING THEM THE BEST FOODS.
SO OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF THAT I'VE BEEN
THERE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
COMPLETELY OVERHAUL ARE A FOOD
PROGRAM WE ARE COOKING FROM
SCRATCH AGAIN.
WE HAVE SALAD BARS AND ALL OF
OUR SCHOOLS -- AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PURCHASE SOME ORGANIC
PRODUCE DAIRY.
AND MEAT -- THERE'S MANY
CHALLENGES IN SCHOOL FOOD THE
BIGGEST PROBABLY BEING THAT I
HAVE ABOUT A DOLLAR TWENTY FIVE
TO SPEND PER CHILD PER MEAL PER
DAY AND I'M FEEDING EIGHT
THOUSAND KIDS PER DAY.
I'M THIS BILL WOULD HELP ME TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO FEED THE
CHILDREN OF THE NAPA VALLEY THE
BEST FOOD POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU
VERY MUCH EXPERTS AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT -- YEAH DAY RENTS AND
POLICY DIRECTOR COMMUNITY LINES
FAMILY FARMERS.
WE'VE JOINED WITH ENERGY SEATED
CO SPONSOR THIS BILL AND I'M.
YEAH WE OPERATE A PROGRAM THAT
HELPS SCHOOLS SOURCE -- CAL OF
FOOD FROM CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
SO WE VERY MUCH AS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING AB NINE
FIFTY EIGHT I'M LLENA BROKE
DIRECTOR FEED CAMPAIGNS OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WE ARE CO SPONSORING
THIS LEGISLATION.
AND I ALSO WANT TO JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
WE ALSO URGE FOR EUROPE.
I VOTE AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY IS THAT THIS BILL
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
CHILDREN AND FOR THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF OUR STATES ORGANIC
FARMERS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYBODY ELSE BECAUSE
SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE NAME
AND AT THE MICROPHONE.
MICHAEL DEMOCRATS OF CHANGE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THERESA BERG ****
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COALITION IN SUPPORT.
BEST SPELLER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARMING NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
BEST SMOKER WITH PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER FROM SAN DIEGO
I'M AND WITH EMPOWER FAMILY --
CALIFORNIA MY HUSBAND IS A STE --
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND I'M AN
EDUCATIONAL PARALEGAL AND WE ARE
VERY FIRMLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI CRYSTAL THE BURCHETT FROM
EDUCATE ADVOCATE I'M FROM RANCHO
CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
PART HOURS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIAN VINYL HEALTH
INITIATIVE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GREEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEPHANIE STEVENS OF THE NEVADA
COUNTY FOOD POLICY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HE REACHED
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TODAY.
SEEING NONE I WOULD BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO SAY OF I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I WONDER IF EVERYBODY
SITTING APPEARS WHEN YOUR
CONSTITUENTS -- MAYBE OKAY.
AND I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR I THINK WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I'VE TRIED TO
WORK ON AS WELL AS HOW DO WE GET
MORE OF OUR GREAT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IN TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED AT THE VERY MOST.
OF OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS.
OKAY I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A YORKER SIMPLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE AND TO KNOW
THAT OUR CHILDREN WILL BE GIVEN
THIS CHANCE TO TRY SOME OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN ORGANIC FOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO EDUCATION
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN NINE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AG YEAR CURRY HI A YEAR
CURRY I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY -- WHEN -- WHEN
NINE JONES SAWYER RIGHT JONES
SAWYER I'D QUIRK AYE QUIRK GUY
ROBERT RIVAS?
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN WITHOUT THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF ISSUE WE ADD ON THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR THE CONSENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON MR LEVIN'S A. B.. EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT WHICH WAS PRESENTED BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE AYE [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
I GRAY.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM I THE END ON
EGGMAN A. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT LARA.
FLORA I'D GRAY.
QUIRK HI QUIRK GUY [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR MEETING TODAY
I WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FOR
FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH -- ZERO
THE SHOES ON THAT'S GOOD
.
MAN OF ENTRIES WITHIN WAITING.
FOR EXACTLY -- JUST WANTED TO DO
IT.
ON THE COUNTER AB EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AB EIGHTEEN NO ONE ON
THREE NINE AB [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT I EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY GREAT.
GREAT I EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT
GREAT I AGREE I WE NEED TO TURN
[inaudible]
WITHIN.
EVERYTHING FROM ELEVEN SAID
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
NEXT GENERATION -- IS THE LINE
SYSTEM.
IF YOU HAVE THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
WHERE IS THAT?
ONE YEAH THIS [inaudible]
ONE GOT A THERE MODOC FRIDAY
[inaudible]
THE LAW.
OKAY SO I'LL